privacy is an assistant professor in the
computer science and engineering
division at the University of Michigan
he received his PhD in computer science
from kth Royal Institute of Technology
in 2018 advised by danan nankai between
2018 to 2020 he was a research assistant
professor at Toyota Toyota technological
Institute at Chicago and he works on
Dynamic graph algorithms and has a broad
interest in modern models of computation
including online sublinear parallel and
DET and
distributed thanks a lot okay um so
today I will talk about how to deal with
adaptive adversary using differential
privacy and this is a joint work with a
lot of amazing people who know much more
on differential privacy than me uh so
one is one of them is time here okay so
um but I just kind of excited about this
connection and basically although I'm
not the expert I want to share with with
you okay so uh first of all um in this
talk there will be two type of adversary
that we consider one is oblivious
adversary this is a like so first of all
adversary is just the guy who gener
generate updates to our data structure
and O adversary is such
that it will fix the whole update
sequence from the beginning and review
the update sequence to you to the data
structure one by one so everything is
fixed from the beginning so that's why
it's called oblivious doesn't depends on
the on what data structure
return another one is adaptive adversary
this is the adversary such that the next
update is generated based on previous
answer of the
algorithm so this this one is stronger
than this one we want to get the data
structure uh that works against adaptive
adversary in many setting for example
when we want to um use it as a sub
routine inside um static
algorithm and for this talk I will use
this word for for short like the
algorithm is robust if it works against
adaptive adversary otherwise if it only
works against op ad adversary I said
that is non
robust and yeah what we going to see is
a blackbox
transformation from any robust n any
non-rust algorithm to the robust
one for estimation problem so is a
problem when you want to maintain let's
say one number okay using differential
Pary and the goal is that like like
basically you will see two cool property
from differential pracy that I think is
is good to know even if you care about
data structure only and and um another
is like you'll see how they like combine
how this property combine together and
give us this blackbox
transformation so this again this is
based on the joint work with uh um this
like many people including him okay so
let's see um let's see the reduction
it's going to be simple
but before we go to the real reduction
let's let's talk about the the setting
just set up some notation so let's say
that X is your input that under goes the
update okay and so like XI I we use it
to denote the input at the I step at the
ice time so it's just a initial input x0
after applying ice many
updates U One U2 U u3 until UI it's just
a update that like that you give to the
input like you can think of this as a
initial graph and this is a age update
to the graph for
example and I will use x Vector I to
denote the sequence the update sequence
from the beginning up to time I Okay so
what's really happening is like you have
adversary at time I it give us the I
update and you have algorithm a which
output what it answer based on the
update sequence it seen so
far that's a simple uh
setting
now I will we will consider Dynamic
algorithm for estimation problem so what
do I mean by this exactly so when you
have X at the input uh that under like
Dynamic input let's set that t of X is
just some function depending on the
input can be size of the minimum cut uh
St distance um anything just some some
function okay so algorithm with the
algorithm maintain gamma approximation
of G of x if for every step I well um
the algorithm
given the update sequence up to time I
return something that is within like a
gamma factor of G of
XI all right so that's the setting and
now let's see one very simple blackbox
transformation yes I would imagine this
is in a probabilistic setting so do you
need probability somewhere good so I
want I want this thing to hold for every
step I let's say with prob probability
at least Point N for every
step no for all steps actually
yeah okay
so let's see at least one simple uh
Black Block
transformation okay suppose right
suppose that you have a non-rust
algorithm a such that it maintain Gam my
approximation of some
function and this is correct throughout
the whole
sequence of T updates with probability
0.9 and let's say that it can handle
this sequence of T Min updates using t
total total update
time well how to get a robust one that
is um like you'll see it soon but like
um
that we can get like a robust algorithm
a prime right that maintain our gamma
approximation with the same probability
such that the total time to handle T
update is t total times
T okay and um let's see the so basically
that is like a blow up of T yeah
the okay let's see how to do this uh
well um we just kind of do something
almost trivial that is we initialize to
many copies of non-rust algorithm A1 up
to
a and for each step I just feed the
update UI to every copy of a and then
return the answer of AI at step
I so why this is robust this is because
well we use Rand like the
we okay the randomness of AI is leaked
only at step I but once we use some like
once this information is leaked to
adversary we never use um AI
again but you see that like okay this
works but the the total update time is
blow up by a factor of t
so now um let's see how to get something
a bit
better suppose we give like we are in
the same setting uh you have a non-rust
algorithm okay such that it hand handle
T update into t total
time what we're going to see today is
that we can get a robust algorithm a
prime that
maintain gamma Plus gamma * 1 + Alpha
just a bit worse approximation with
probability like can be even better
doesn't matter too much here and um it
can handle T many updates using t total
times Ro t total update time yes good
question so you mentioned that the
Adaptive adversaries only sees the
previous outputs but doesn't see the
randomness of does it make a difference
a lot of the difference so like the an
the question is like whether like this
is it important to say that um the
adverse the Adaptive adversary see only
previous answer and not the random
Choice inside the algorithm and that's
the answer is yes we only assume that it
only see the answer and this is crucial
for this technique to
work yeah I mean just going on that
doesn't that reduce the
applicability like I get yeah so yeah
this is still quite applicable because
when when you use data structure to
interact with like to like when you use
data structure inside as a sub routine
in the static
algorithm the way that the algorithm
interact with data structure is usually
just depends on the answer it doesn't
really try to see how you use Randomness
inside
okay good good question oh good
questions uh all right so you see like
we get this Improvement of r t
yeah so this is just a simple to State
um thing there will be like a more
advanced version of this whole thing and
it give like uh a bunch of application
to um Dynamic graph algorithms like um
previously
like adaptive algorithm algorithm robust
algorithm are quite slow and with this
techniques you get like something that
is non-trivial although not not as fast
as the previous
one anyway uh this is the what we want
to look at today the simple to State uh
transformation okay so let's see the the
description of this
transformation is quite simple too okay
so what we're going to do is instead of
having T many copies just create SC T
many copies of non-rust
algorithm A1 up to AC and C is right
around Ro
T and for at I
step okay we do the same thing we feed
eyes up there to every copy of
a and after that
what we going to do we return the median
of all the answer we have seen after R
routed up by power of 1 plus uh
Alpha so you just look at what each
copies of a
return draw up a bit and then return the
median almost this is almost whole
thing
um except that the correct like the
preise the precise description is just
that instead of median I changed this to
something called private
median that's it that's the that's the
description um and you will I will not
actually describe how exactly it's
simple how to do this thing and but I I
I would just talk first what exactly
what does it mean to be private um
here are you going to say where you need
to
round um I just want to round so that
um okay the question is why we need to
round the answer is we want to round
just so that um
the the universe of numbers that we will
ever see is finite um it's not like you
don't want you don't want to work with
real numbers you will see soon why we
need this in the in the promise of from
the this like from the property of
private median we need to work with
finite
universe
so so that's the description but now we
want to see like why why like why why
does it even mean here private median
and yeah this is going to be about
differential privacy so let me tell you
what what it
is
so um so let's say that you have a set
um s which is a list of elements from
Universe
X they're going to say that an
algorithm is Epsilon Dela differential
private or Epsilon Delta DP
if for any input S and S Prime differing
differing on one
entries but differing on one entri is
here depends on on like on your
application it can be Um this can be a
table and it differ on one row um it can
this two can be two graph differ by one
H or one note depends on on your your
application and what you want to concern
uh what you concern okay so given two
input S and S S Prime differing on one
entry and if you look at any subset of
outputs of possible output O then you
want that the probability
that a given this input s and answer
something in the set all is basically
the same probability when you change the
input from s to S
Prime so we have multip itive factor and
additive Factor
here the additive Factor here you should
think of something like really small one
po this one you can think of small
constant in other words um the output of
a is
stable uh under change of the input so
privacy is just stability of the
algorithm
so so you want this thing to be like
smaller the smaller the better the
smaller the more stable you
get okay and private median um is the
algorithm that do this okay you have a
list of elements from like totally order
universe and the sub routine private
median
is an algorithm that is differential
differentially
private something
like one / s
private um and it runs in time basically
linear in the size of the
input and here you have log X so that's
why you don't want to work with real
number you want this thing to be like
finite and what it does is just it
returns like some element in the
universe this element X might not be
from your set by the way but the rank of
X with respect to your set should be
something close to
median close to
half so it's really just median
approximate median but is
private okay
so you just think from now that if you
have a set of size s you can return a
median of it such that the Privacy is
something like One
S okay so now just kind of explain I
just explained the like the input output
of private median and that
basically um complet the whole
description um and you see that the
total time that we need to spend s t
total Times Square Root
T because we really just run root T many
copies um of this of
a yes can you just the say one word
about what specific plus distribution
you're sampling over if it's kind of an
unstructured
set
um I mean go to go inside this this
thing right um yeah I mean you have it a
comment assume you can sample right I
was just wondering what the plus
distribution it
is
um can we take this offline I mean it's
it's not this simple but I just kind of
want to skip this for a bit yeah
thanks yes so I'm wondering what if uh
you don't fit the update uh UI to every
copy you sample just few few copies and
then um then you can somehow uh exploit
B Dynamic algorithms so you know if good
question so the question is can we
instead of feed everything to to all
every copies and just
subsample these copies and just so I
will get to that soon it's is definitely
the way to to speed up this framework
yeah it works
yeah okay so the rest of this talk I
will just now show you at least why how
things fit together like and why a is
now like should be still accurate even
against adaptive
adversary so um
so the main step is this the first step
I will try to convince you is that the
random string the random choice that we
feed to each copy AJ are
private and this is really the most
important Insight of this technique
actually the Privacy is to protect the
random string it's not to protect like
it's not on the answer of of the of a no
no it's not on the input of a it's on
the random string of
a sorry this should be
input once you get that your random
string is private then you will we can
show that most of the copies are
accurate and once you know that most of
the copy are accurate then because you
return the median of this cop of this
answer of the of you return the median
of this copies then then your a prime
must be
accurate and for each step like I will
tell you how we applied uh differential
two differential privacy properties
which is one is adaptive composition
another is generalization these are the
two cool thing that I like I think it's
good to know uh is the sare type for
this I think for this techniques um this
quity is tight
yeah and uh does it come from the
tightness of the Adaptive
composition yes you always see yeah
right this is TI
because um I
mean you get this up about OB using
adaptive
composition um that the lower bound um
is that is a lower mile from adaptive
data analysis um that
give like that give the tightness of
this
technique all right so so I wanted to
First tell you about this
thing so what is adaptive composition
well we said that
a is compos is a composition of A2 and
A1 on input
s if it compus first like A1 given the
input and then it output out out out one
and then A2 look at the input as well as
the output of A1 and it output R2 okay
so this is why it's adaptive like A2
also look at the output from A1 and give
you out out output two
okay and a just output this both outputs
here this is then if if a works like
this then then like we said that a is
adaptive composition of A2 and
A1 and now what's cool about
differential Pary is that um like
the you
get it preserve privacy under adaptive
composition so if you have K copies of
uh this Epsilon Z DP
algorithms and you compose K mini K mini
uh K mini algorithm here
adaptively then one can show one can
anal Analyze This and like the first
basic analysis show that a is K Epsilon
private but with a better analysis one
can also show that actually if you are
willing to pay some additive error here
and this this can be super
small then you a actually is something
like square root
K
private yes like the loss in privacy
here is just from Epsilon you get loss
of something like square root
K and with some something here but like
uh this is going to be negligible
because you get Epsilon Square
here so the reason why we have like this
square root K here is going to be the
reason why we get square root
Improvement and Epsilon here will be
chosen such that this is
negligible and the very high level
intuition why you get square root K
instead of K at all is like kind of when
you do K random walks in 1D you should
be like within root root K instead of K
from the
original so anyway that's adaptive
composition let's let's use
it to show that your random string are
private so I would need some notation
again um
so let's say that I use RJ to denote the
random string used by the non-rust copy
AJ and capital r is just this collection
of
rjs and output at time I out Prime I of
J is just an output of a prime at step I
when this collection R is fed to this
nonrobust copies so like given the I at
the I time here right given the I update
this algorithm a prime return the
private median of this copy J when this
is a input so like update sequence so
far and this guy depends on this random
string RJ and you return this private
median and this is just the output at
time
I so the transcript between algorithm a
prime and adversary is just this topple
like this update and
output and um the transcript of the
whole thing is
just you get like initial input and the
transcript at every time
step okay so what I'm what I'm going to
do next is just to show you that this
whole
transcript is private with with respect
to R so
like so like this transcript is stable
right when you change like some like
when one of the like when when you
change one random string in this
collection R this this whole transcript
is
stable so meaning that this transcript
doesn't reveal this information about
the the random string
so uh why is this
well first of all if you fix any
eye the transcript at time I is just a
update and this output at time
I I claim that this is going to be
something like um one / C private reason
is just this
output this output at time I is just a
private median of C many
numbers
and so um this thing is going to be one
/ C
private and then the transcript at time
I is just like um it's just a proessing
of of this thing it's just a function
depending on on out out I prime of R
so the transcript at time I is something
like one / C
private so 1 / root T
private but then once you look at the
the transcript over all time step this
is just the Adaptive composition of TI
over r
t and then you you do the advanc
decomposition and then you get like your
privacy will get worse by a factor of
root T because this is the Adaptive
composition of T many things get wor by
root t
[Music]
and then you chose C here right to be C
here is big enough so it canel with r
t then you you you should see you should
see to be like something like big enough
like close like root T times polog say
and then this is like small constant
now all right hope this makes
sense what were the two parts again
sorry oh with the you had the DP
elements one was adaptive composition
and the other one was uh
basic uh yeah no no generalization
generalization oh yeah yeah yeah I I
didn't I didn't talk about that yet yeah
yeah okay so this is just a first step
um so far we we have that um this
transcript is private okay now we're
gonna use the fact that this transcript
is private
um with like with respect to this random
string to to claim that
actually each um each copies AJ here
actually will return something quite
accurate at H time this will use
generalization of
DP and
okay let me tell you what it
is so to talk about it I need to start
with like some warm up which is let's
say that D is some distribution over
some domain X and let's say I fix some
predicate
H replicate that map X to Z or
one if you want to estimate the
expectation of this thing
like like how in what's the fraction
of of x from from from this distribution
that give one to to this to H that's
easy well you can just sample like
something like one/ uh Epsilon Square
independent elements from d and just
average and then by China off you get X
you get like this concentration and this
is all
good so this is this is when this is
true like when the empirical average
give you the the real expectation then
it we said that this samples s
generalized to D to this
this however this clearly completely
failed if s
here you if you can choose H here
depending on the sample set s is if it
if H is adaptive because H can totally
overfit the the sample set like you can
choose some some Edge such that like for
everything in the your sample it give
one for
example but now next slide you'll see
that actually if H here is chosen by
private
algorithm then you still get
generalization even if H is chosen
adaptively
so so that let's say what I mean exactly
so and conceptually like this is like
the most important property at least to
me uh like um of of DP uh
okay so um you have the same this dist D
here let's say you have this s like s is
just a sample T independent sample from
from the distribtion
D and
now suppose that you have an
algorithm that given a
sample it
chose this predicate H depending on the
sample so s actually depend on on
S now the point is that if this
algorithm actually is
private
it turns out that this empirical average
here is going to be the
same like similar to the
expectation with some
error so this is really cool to me and
like what does it say it says that
generalization is
guarantee as long as H is chosen by
private
algorithm even H is adaptive doesn't
matter if it is chosen by P private
algorithm you get
generalization and this makes sense um
because the output of private algorithm
are stable
enough right such that like this guy H
cannot o cannot manage to overfit the
the
sample but we would take this um like
and um
okay we just believe
this and we'll see how to use
it actually just stupid question so if H
depends on the sample how do you define
the first
expectation because it should depend on
the whole
sequence like the expectation in green
only has one
sample oh right and somehow H is
supposed to depend on T samples I'm just
no uh so H is a function of one element
in X right so here you just sample X
independently from everything and look
at the what what is this value and look
at expectation here you you just look at
the empirical average of X from your
sample right okay
so first take the empirical sample then
choose H then evaluate it on
expectation the entire distribution
that's the
left so even the number on the left kind
of depends on the sample because AG
depends on the sample yeah the number on
this the number on on the left here
depends on the can depends on S because
s depend on S
okay
good so this is important slide and it's
good to know this one even though you
you don't care about the rest of the
talk um so yeah there's no dependence on
S in the AA like the size of s is no
dependence on S on what again like size
of s no no there is no size of
this there's no dependency on S
here all
right okay let's see how to use this
generalization of private
privacy
um
okay um so last notation is this thing
um I I said that accuracy given
R when the input is Xi is just indicator
whether like a given this random string
and the sequence update sequence
XI like is accurate whether this is
accurate like that it return this gamma
approximation and okay
so I said that this U is like a
distribution uniform distribution and R
here just again the collection of of
random um string that we feed to each
sample that we Feit to each copies of
the non robust
algorithm so just from this notation you
have that this accuracy of RJ for the
sequence up to I the update sequence up
to I this one is one exactly if if AJ is
accurate at time
I and now let me ask you this like I
claim that
um this
thing accurate of XI for R star when you
sample our star from uniformly
independent of everything this must be
at least
0.9 so why why is
that when R star is just random string
independent from from the input sequence
this accuracy must be
high
well the reason is just this this is
because this is precisely the guarantee
of nonrobust
algorithm
right so non-rust algorithm when your
like random string is independent from
the input you get a good
guarantee this is for one IE one I for
each eye um yeah for one eye yeah
okay last technical slide um so last two
actually sorry um
so okay you have this collection of R
here okay and you have this
definition now I claim
that this thing that looks like
expectation and this thing that looks
like empirical average is close to each
other and why are we done with if we
have this because I will show proof this
claim in the next slide why but given
this why are we done because we know
that this
thing is Big it's close to 0.9 it's at
least 0. n so this
thing it's like big like
89 because they are close to each other
here what does it mean here it means
that most of AJ is accurate at time I
like AJ is is accurate at time I for
most I because this is just two this is
this is one if AJ is accurate at time
I so most of it is
accurate and if you return the median of
this of of the answer from from AJ you
would you would be
correct so now I just need to show you
why this expectation and emical average
is is close to each other well we of
course use
generalization and um what we're going
to do is to view this transcript as an
algorithm that given the collection R
and output this
predicate so
like like when you give like when you
fix this collection of of random string
r fit it like when you fix this then the
transcript will determine what is the
the input so far like the the update
sequence up to time I which deter me
whether like this function that depends
on on X XI like the update sequence up
to
XI so so it means what it means that
this thing like we we know before that
this transcript is priv with respect to
R so it's a private
algorithm and so like this thing is like
a predicate chosen by private
algorithm and so by generalization of
the private privacy you get
that this is a private this predicate
that is chosen by private
algorithm must be close like this this
empirical average must be close to to
expectation
okay just going back to actually had a
question about how many how Big C be
like you don't have the same thing that
c should be at least some you know one
over Epsilon Square
size like well see see here I shows it
to be even like root T so uh right right
okay yeah so but but there is something
about C needing to be big need to be
quite B yeah yeah all right I'm kind of
out of time so
um so you see that most AJ are accurate
and so a prime is accurate okay so let
me conclude we get this um like
transformation such that you get this
factor of root T and um there are some
extension you get can get speed up using
sub clamping that chai um mentioned and
um you can speed up using another
technique but let me conclude with a
quick open problem so far this
transformation works for estimation
problem it would be cool to have some
blackbox transformation for search
problem like um maximum matching
um maximal independent set anything yeah
um this is some concrete problem that I
would love to see um robust algorithm
and if there are more conditional L that
would be cool yeah thanks a lot
[Applause]
thanks a great talk we have about two
minutes for
questions so one of the issues resarch
propos is there too much information in
yes yeah we review a lot of information
so yeah that's yeah it's it's not clear
how to do
it thanks do you think this routy is a
bottleneck for a differential privacy
based
approach I think so um I think at least
like in the streaming P like in the
streaming setting where um like time and
other people did before like there is
some tight Bound for this approach for
routy yeah
okay but
so uh if I only care about if there's a
very big matching or very small matching
I only I want to distinguish these two
cases then I want to know if my output
is larger than 0.99 or less than
0.1 um is routy tight can we beat
routy I am not sure uh like this
technique doesn't give that Improvement
directly like I don't see how to exploit
that yeah I see yeah
I'm a bit I thought you said the Routan
can be improved it's up something oh no
I mean so good it can be improved like
the number of copies I don't see how to
improve this but the
implementation of this whole thing can
be speed up instead of given um updates
to rout te many copies at each time step
you just sample lock in among this
copies and fed the update to to those
guy so like so the overall update time
would be yeah the update time like from
the perspective of of the each nonr
algorithm like it will sample only root
T times um throughout the whole sequence
of T update instead of T
times
good question like um yeah this thing
don't I don't see how to improve but
there are ways to improve the
implementation last one last question um
so your guarantee was um at each time
step you have a 0. n uh
your like on average you'll like succeed
in like 0 uh
90% uh% of the is there an easy way to
boost this with high
probability so all of this thing that we
we St like this probability can be boost
uh uh to to to high probability easily
okay just make copies yeah okay so that
wouldn't mess up with the differential
privacy no okay
thanks thanks G thank
[Applause]
you yeah we'll have a 30-minute coffee